[Música]
Netflix anunció el final de sus cuentas
compartidas Hace un año determinó que
más de 100 millones de hogares no pagan
en todo el mundo para cambiar esa fuga
de ingresos en adelante familiares o
amigos que quieran disfrutar del
contenido bajo una misma suscripción
Ahora tendrán que estar Bajo el mismo
techo o pagar más dinero cómo nos
veremos afectados a la larga y qué
pasará con Netflix vamos a conversarlo
con Javier López quien es el caster y
creador de contenidos digitales también
es divulgador en la web de noticias
tecnológicas
21 Muchísimas gracias Javier algunos
comentarios sobre la decisión de Netflix
de restringir las pantallas y evitar que
se compartan fuera del hogar apuntan a
una crisis del gigante ante la alta
Competencia por otras plataformas pero
usted cree que esto es señal de crisis o
de que la compañía lo está haciendo bien
y por eso puede darse este lujo de
cobrar a más personas
Buenos días Bueno yo creo que hay un
poco de las dos cosas por un lado es
innegable que el modelo que tenía
Netflix con su política de cuentas
compartidas no era sostenible en el
tiempo las empresas necesitan aumentar
la rentabilidad constantemente y en los
últimos años hemos visto como el número
de suscriptores de pago Se iba
desacelerando a medida que llegaban
nuevos competidores y el mercado también
se ve autorregulaba si hubieran seguido
permitiendo que las cuentas se pudieran
compartir alegremente habrían llegado a
una crisis financiera Así que hubieran
tenido una crisis yo creo que de ahí que
hayan optado por tomar medidas a tiempo
cuando su popularidad Todavía es muy muy
alta y son el referente dentro del mundo
del streaming de vídeo pero por otro
lado y yo creo que de forma
complementaria la posición de la que
gozan serán ganado a base de tomar
decisiones en muchos casos arriesgadas
casi siempre con mucho éxito y quizás
por eso no les ha temblado el pulso al
tomar una decisión tan polémica yo
personalmente creo que lo hacen muy bien
A pesar de que la medida sea
tremendamente impopular y afecte
negativamente a los usuarios
bueno es que esas son las ventajas en
algunas ocasiones de llegar primero no
al estar en este lugar pues Netflix ha
podido tener esa esa posibilidad de de
moverse dentro del mercado
específicamente en América Latina Quiero
preguntarle cómo nos va a afectar a
nosotros o Cómo cree usted que nos va a
afectar teniendo en cuenta pues que
nuestros valores de salario mínimo son
diferentes y que es muy frecuente que
como usuarios no solamente consumamos
Netflix sino que consumamos otras
plataformas es decir se lleva una parte
importante del salario mínimo este rubro
de entretenimiento a través de las
plataformas
Sí a ver América Latina tiene una
situación en cierta medida similar a lo
que ocurre aquí en España los salarios
medios son bajos y es muy habitual que
la gente comparta suscripciones con
amigos con otros familiares que viven
lejos en este sentido la decisión de
Netflix es como un jarro de agua fría
que solemos decir por aquí porque va a
hacer que cambie la forma en la que
consumimos entretenimiento en streaming
seguramente haya que darse de alta y de
baja para poder ver contenidos en meses
sueltos y lo que está claro es que con
la escalada de precios y la restricción
de las cuentas compartidas no vamos a
poder estar abonados a todo vamos a
tener que empezar a elegir
entre tanto otras plataformas por el
momento al menos y al menos en América
Latina mantienen cierta libertad de
conexión si quiere llamarlo así Usted
cree que se moverán en la misma
dirección de Netflix
yo creo que que sí Este es un movimiento
que no no tiene retorno yo creo que de
hecho ya han empezado a mover ficha en
Estados Unidos Disney Plus la antigua
hbo Max que ahora la han rebautizado
como Max o Prime video no van a tardar
en hacer lo mismo a escala global Irán
haciéndolo por regiones por zonas
geográficas pero Yo calculo que en un
par de años estén todas más o menos
igual y puede que utilicen Esa esa carta
como una herramienta más para atraer a
potenciales clientes de forma que si nos
damos de alta por primera vez a lo mejor
en un servicio no activen la
geolocalización y nos dejen compartir la
cuenta durante un tiempo pero desde
luego yo creo que este movimiento de
Netflix hace que entremos en un nuevo
escenario una pregunta que me surge a mí
como como usuaria de estas plataformas
es que pasa si me quiero ir de viaje y
abrir mi cuenta desde una dirección
diferente a mi hogar o a mi dirección IP
normal
Netflix todavía está lidiando un poco
con los problemas técnicos de una
decisión tan compleja como la de
restringir El acceso a nuestra cuenta
porque no es algo sencillo de
acortar no a los pocos días de activarse
esta restricción Netflix lo que sí que
hizo fue pedir a los usuarios que
confirmaran su ubicación permanente para
posicionar nuestra vivienda habitual Así
que cuando nos vamos de viaje tenemos
dos opciones básicamente por un lado
podemos
descargarnos el contenido para verlo
offline estemos donde estemos en viajes
en desplazamientos en vacaciones y la
otra opción es que la plataforma sí que
es capaz de detectar que estamos de
viaje y al combinar la IP pública desde
la que estamos accediendo al servicio
con otros datos como el identificador
del dispositivo y en ese sentido Netflix
nos da la posibilidad de pulsar un botón
que pone estoy de viaje que es
precisamente lo que tendremos que hacer
para que nos faciliten un código bien a
través de SMS o por correo electrónico
con el cual durante 14 días podremos
Acceder al servicio desde fuera de
nuestra vida vivienda habitual otra cosa
es que ya nos vayamos a otra vivienda
vayamos a estar más tiempo y en ese caso
sí que tendremos que cambiar nuestra
ubicación y
modificarlo pero para viajes cortos para
vacaciones para estancias cortas podemos
descargarlo o podemos solicitar un
código temporal bueno fíjese que las
sensaciones de una cierta pérdida de
libertad de los usuarios alrededor del
uso de las plataformas ya para mi
pregunta final quisiera tener su opinión
sobre cómo están evolucionando las
maneras de consumo de las plataformas
Porque es diferente el ambiente al que
se enfrentan hoy las compañías de
streaming al que se enfrentó Netflix
cuando hizo su lanzamiento hace algunos
años cómo se va a mover esto hacia el
futuro Usted qué opina
la verdad es que va a ser muy divertido
verlo un poco desde fuera pero sí que es
cierto que estamos en una auténtica
guerra del streaming en marcha ya lleva
un tiempo fraguándose pero yo creo que
estamos llegando al punto álgido No solo
porque han llegado nuevos competidores
sino porque yo creo que el mercado ya
está maduro en el sentido de que la
gente ya se ha acostumbrado a pagar por
el streaming ya estamos habituados a
tener una o varias suscripciones y en
ese sentido lo que sí que vamos a ver es
que el modelo de televisión por cable en
la televisión convencional lineal que
está en un declive Yo creo que con el
tiempo el streaming va a prevalecer y va
a sobreponerse sobre esa televisión
tradicional y es probable que el día de
mañana pues veamos plataformas como
Netflix o como hbo Max con canales en
abierto que emitan en directo pues
eventos deportivos o grandes
transmisiones multitudinarias pero desde
luego yo no me imagino un futuro como el
que teníamos hace 10 15 años sin el
streaming yo creo que esto ha venido
para quedarse y Tendremos que adaptarnos
a lo que ellos nos vayan indicando No
porque nos marcan el camino pues mire Yo
le agradezco mucho es Javier López
comunicador y podcaster y creador
también de contenidos digitales que
tenga un feliz día Igualmente gracias
También a nuestros televidentes pero
quédense ya regresamos con más
[Música]